turning now to our candid conversation
with musician Amanda shires she was on
the verge of quitting music she said
when she made her latest album It's
called take it like a man now it's being
held by critics as one of country's best
recent albums she's very proud of this
work the New York Times says quote
here's a spirit of Outlaw country in
2022 a Fearless woman Gathering all her
strength and belting out her truths with
a poet's diction and a bird of Praise
voices I like that awesome I like that
too in addition to her acclaimed solo
work chars is also known for founding
the all-female super group The High
women with Brandy Carlisle maren Morris
and Natalie him Natalie himby all
superstars in their own were in their
own right as well as her as well as her
work with her husband's band that's
Jason Isbell and the 400 unit Nate and I
recently sat down with shires to discuss
her album marriage and motherhood Tony
was off because he had the Rona that's
the only reason why he wasn't here but
here's that interview
I want to talk about your music because
you have said everything on this record
is autobiographical you didn't hold
anything back so what was your thought
process what was your mind State when
you were writing well I at first was
when I was writing I was like the worst
that could happen is I don't like the
song and nobody has to hear it and then
I'll write something that I like or feel
comfortable with or even want to
investigate in the studio you sing about
things that are struggles most people
will not admit to even within your
marriage right were there difficult
times when you were writing or even
recording oh definitely you know I feel
like the more that we talk about these
things like my grandparents were married
forever and they said marriage is hard
but I never understood what that was but
it also feels like if you talk about
marriage you're doing something
um
I don't know unfair to them yeah in
society yeah it's too personal yeah it
feels like cheating or betraying yeah if
you talk about it but I think it's more
helpful it's therapeutic I do think it's
therapeutic you're of course married to
Jason Hezbollah and you you were very
candid about problems that you all had
had in your marriage and he encouraged
you to release a song that could be
could be very vulnerable for people who
are listening that's kind of the job
though um in the end I was I was wasn't
sure I wanted to answer questions about
it and his advice was you don't have to
or you can tell it from your side
because it is you know it's your story
and I think the job though is that
writers say the hard thing so other
people can have language for those hard
things
I think I was worried about the
questions and then
about
um
criticisms in and not in the music
musical sense but in the way that I was
talking about
my marriage with my personal life yeah
my personal life but at the same time it
feels like the pressure's off to
maintain the always
Shiny Happy married people it's not
always sunshine and rainbow yeah no and
people don't talk about it and then if
that normal you don't know if you're
supposed to keep going through the hard
times to make it through some yeah
potential hopeful you come out on the
other side maybe you do are you and
Jason okay today can we today yes we are
yes okay I'm glad but I'm so fascinated
Amanda by your voice I I don't even know
how to describe it and maybe that's the
point that you can't really be
pigeonholed into any kind of genre
right do you feel that
um the voice thing is part of the reason
I almost quit because one person told me
let's go more note
but that's okay we've forgotten about
that I'm insulting yeah but it's all
good uh I don't know how to describe it
except for
I don't know I learned to play violin
first yeah it's beautifully unique well
thank you and that's okay yeah
beautifully it sounds a little bit like
uh braggy beautifully unique
you've earned the right to say that
exactly there are people that are
beginning their Journey young teenagers
that are looking at maybe marriage or
getting into the music industry trying
to figure out who they are what they
want to do
what advice do you have for them I I
think the the thing that worked for me a
lot was showed up on time and when
people say be a team player it's not as
much about being a team player as it is
understanding group dynamics like
understanding a person is going through
something that you don't know what
they're going through and and you are as
well but to to kind of give Grace in the
situation of humans and the other thing
is always pack a swimsuit
yeah you never know are you ready you
never know about what swimming
there could be a pool there could be a
hot tub I like that I like that okay
that's really good I'm gonna remember
Amanda shires that always packs always
pack a swimsuit and talk to us about
being a mom you have a young daughter
Mercy what is the message you're sending
to her that whatever thing she falls in
love with and um
is passionate about she should do and
then if she should
find something wrong in the world she
should change it if she can
I just think that you are so cool and
your voice is so beautiful and I can't
wait for us to be blessed with your
performance today thank you thank you
well thank you so much I'm honor